- It was just sort of
thing where, you know,
all my friends were like,
lets go do recruitment,
and I was like, okay!
(laughs)
(lighthearted music)
- Initially, I actually didn't
want to join a sorority.
I've had trouble keeping girlfriends
just as platonic friends.
- I grew up with sisters and brothers
and I wanted to find something that was
that kind of community.
- I guess I was out when I joined, yeah,
I don't think I was ever
like, particularly closeted
cuz I was lucky enough
to go to a high school
that was pretty accepting.
- I was not out about my sexuality,
but I've always been open
about sex in general.
- Before I went to my specific sorority's
open house and rush, I
went to other ones where
there was girly and one
way of kind of living
and I was like, that's
not me, I need a spectrum.
- Going into the rush process
it wasn't a huge concern of
mine, because I kinda figured
if people aren't going to
accept me for who I am,
then I don't wanna be a
part of your sorority.
(laughs)
- I knew one girl, she
was out, in my society
but that doesn't mean that
people won't talk about you
behind closed doors just
because they're open
and accepting in the moment.
So, it does kinda scare me sometimes.
You don't know what kinda
situations you're gonna walk into.
- One of the first people in the sorority
that I came out to was
one of my close friends.
It was just like, wow, okay.
Had all these questions and she was like,
so, how does that work? How does sex work?
- I remember being in this moment,
and it was part of when we
were playing 10 fingers,
and someone asked, oh, has anybody
ever done something with a
girl, and me and this other girl
put our fingers down at the same time,
and I was like, wait, what, you?
And it made us so close
and we found something
where we're like, connected on
and its something crazy
and cool and unexpected.
- We have a particularly
high volume of LGBT members.
I don't know if it's because
my sorority just tends to
foster that whole be
yourself, acceptance vibe.
- It's not really about what people say,
it's how you put yourself out there.
And I'm gonna put myself out there strong,
and this is who I am
and I'm not gonna take shit from no one.
- I mean, my sorority has definitely had
sisters date each other before
and its not a big deal at all, in fact,
we had a couple sisters who
graduated a few years ago
who were like the power
couple of our Sorority.
And they dated for like three years
and they're still together,
and they're like beautiful
and everyone loves them.
I definitely do find it
a little bit ridiculous
when people fear bisexuals or
fear lesbians in sororities
because I'm like, no offense,
but just cuz we're gay
doesn't mean we don't have standards.
(laughs)
- I think that being
LGBT, in my case bisexual,
in this society is just
another fact of life.
I'm gonna be this year's pledge mistress.
In some ways I'm a little bit hesitant.
Like, what if some of
these girls wanna join
but they're not comfortable
with me being openly out
and bisexual, but at the same time,
they need to know what they're
getting into and I'm proud.
And I'm proud to be in a society
and I'm also proud to be
part of this LGBT community.
- So, if you wanna be a
part of it, I say do it.
- I'm, couldn't be happier
with the choices I've made
and the people I've grown close to.
- Honestly, your safety
and your mental health
and your happiness comes first.
So, make sure you're in a safe situation
and leave if they try to haze you.
(laughs)
- Your lifestyle and the people you love
should never hold you back on something,
on anything in the world.
And especially something
that's supposed to give you family.
(lighthearted guitar music)